[Musique]
les pyramides chef-d'oeuvre de l'egypte
ancienne
elles ont hébergé des momies humaine
mais aussi des momies animal souvent
l'animal accompagné le défunt dans l'au
delà ou bien servait de froid
sans les toucher il est endommagé c'est
petit mot me permettent aujourd'hui de
remonter le temps
[Musique]
grâce à la micro tomodensitométrie à
rayons x ponts génère des images 3d la
résolution est 100 fois supérieure à
celle produite par un scanner médical
une fois les bandelettes virtuellement
retirer et secrets de l'oiseau ne sert
pas
[Musique]
et d'un chat se dévoile l'analyse des
doors et des mâchoires à démontrer qu'il
s'agit probablement d'un chaton
domestique âgée de moins de cinq mois
de toute évidence son coût a été brisée
après analyses des ossements d'oiseaux
l'équipe de chercheurs croient qu'il
s'agit d'un faucon crécerelle une petite
espèce d'oiseau de proie comme une à
l'époque qui encore aujourd'hui
[Musique]
quant aux serpents il s'agit d'un cobra
égyptien juvénile momifié la bouche
ouverte il a probablement été maintenus
en captivité toute sa vie d'ailleurs son
quotidien n'était pas de tout repos rien
calcifié déshydratation cros retirer il
serait mort à la suite de coups de fouet
non
voir à l'intérieur d'un être vivant venu
du passé impossible de rester insensible
la micro tomodensitométrie n'est pas la
seule méthode à pouvoir le faire mais
l'une des plus précises elle offre une
véritable autopsie
deux mille ans plus tard
[Musique]